all right so I thought this was this was
uh I said it was interesting Adam DeVine
was on Theo Von show and sometimes
Hollywood people let the cat out of the
bag yeah well it's so hard to get a
movie create created into the Finish
Line especially these days it seems even
harder dude especially comedies nowadays
you have to like mask it this is why
it's a big action comedy because you
really have to go like action action and
then and then it's a comedy but this we
we it's just like it's it's why I was so
happy to work with Sanders company is we
could just go Full Steam on the comedy
as opposed to you know you watch
comedies nowadays and you're like
no this isn't a [__] comedy you're
not where's the jokes like where's the
[__] yeah somebody's gotten kind of bad
huh yeah it kind of sucks yeah movie
comedy movie com yeah there's still good
shows and stuff but like yeah movie
comedy uh it's it's hard but
luckily uh I I'm my theory is I think
I think like Marvel ruined it yeah I
feel like superhero movies kind of
ruined comedies because they people
watch you go to the theater yeah and you
expect to watch something that costs 200
million dollars to make and comedy
movies aren't that aren't that so you're
like well why would I spend the same
amount of money to go watch a little
comedy in the theater
if I could spend the same amount of
money and go see something so okay so I
I don't know he gets more into it okay I
was just gonna say like I I think it
says that because like one of my like
Fondest Memories was going with my mom
to see old school in theaters packed
theater oh yeah everyone dying laughing
is so much better that too Tropic
Thunder yeah
his Step Brothers Step Brothers that's a
great one there's like no digital
effects but like in a pack theater a
good comedy man is one of the best
theater experiences you could ever have
yeah
worth 200 million dollars right you know
and then they still make those movies
kind of funny like they're I mean
they're not comedies but there's like
right there's ants they're like oh my
God is that raccoon talking yeah this is
hilarious at least being a dick now
which it is but uh but yeah so it's not
it's not like a real comedy and then now
they there used to be something like
every Studio would put out several
comedies every every year and there was
like 45 or 46 comedies in the theaters
every year so about every week or every
other week or so there's a new comedy in
the theaters and uh and then now last
year there was like six or seven well
because comedies now are being because
of the budget thing he's saying I will
say this are being uh relegated to
Netflix or uh streaming platforms so
because here's the thing if you're if
you're if if you could spend a little
bit of money make these movies this is a
big deal because there's too many
streaming platforms all these streaming
platforms need content right and they're
not about to spend 200 million dollars
like you said in a [__] Marvel movie
you know but they'll spend like ten
thousand dollars twenty thousand twenty
ten million to 20 million dollars Thirty
million on a little comedy and then
they'll just use it to people go like oh
I have to go to Paramount plus now to
watch it yeah that's pretty much this is
crazy and people need and the crazy
thing is is it feels like people need
comedy more than ever yeah I feel like
they want it I feel yeah so that's what
this movie was it was like and there's
no like hidden message I feel like
nowadays
people like you get to the end of what
you think is a comedy and you're like is
that about global warming
based yeah yeah you're like is this
resource like some deep hidden message
that I'm supposed to I'm supposed to
recycle more or like you know yeah there
has to be something else right oh the
Moon is trans is that what yeah
I [__] love Theo Von he is great the
Moon is trance is that the surprise yeah
okay I drew I guess we do have to think
about that don't we
yeah I agree there's there's a lot of
what was that was a great and that's
what your David Spade and your movie is
about yeah trans Moon yeah
you guys are just the people to to
spread that message oh it's about
Transportation it's about a lot of
vehicles admitting who they really are
the cars wanted to be motorcycles
motorcycles wishing they were scooters
like Adam DeVine divine's hilarious and
righteous gemstones he's hilarious and
Workaholics he's hilarious in everything
he's in honestly he's very funny he's
definitely like the breakout guy out of
those three oh absolutely yeah it's just
it's where things are man oh dude
there's a riveting scene where a short
bus uh admits that he's a skateboard
yeah
and it's yeah Adam is you could tell
that he's like he wants to keep riffing
but he's also like they're gonna clip
this aren't they they're gonna call me
anti-trans aren't they they're already
not making my movies that's a good
and the last thing I want to do is make
a daily wire comedy movie
we're doing it
but the great thing is I mean
I mean it's comedy that came out with
sound of freedom
that was hilarious oh God
it was funny
oh [__] you could walk into a place and
pitch that and yeah and they wouldn't
laugh you out of the room they'd be like
okay by the way did America goes is
there anyone who writes or shamstones
who isn't hilarious no everybody on that
show is actually [__] hilarious well
that's the thing you know because I like
my job now is kind of one of the
funniest scenes I think I've seen
comedically in the past maybe 10 years
was the first season of righteous
gemstones the Outback Steakhouse video
when she's breaking up with him oh my
God that thing is [__] hilarious well
obviously acting and that kind of stuff
but then like I'm she seduced the
teacher it was so the professor of
college
ruined their marriage oh I like pitch
movies uh and every executive is like
yeah but why should we make this movie
now and you're like because it's funny
yeah because it's funny [__] what do
you mean like whatever happened to just
like we want to make people laugh like
it doesn't need to be right yeah right
there it doesn't need to attach itself
to some like hook in the world right now
it doesn't I mean if it does and that's
right then sure these two need to write
a comedy movie together yeah for sure
hell yeah right but it doesn't always
have to it could just be like whatever
happened to just it's funny for funny
sake I know I feel like super bad was
one of the last movies that they kind of
had like that in some ways like that was
real no there were some after super bad
I think I don't think super bad was the
last one no really just super fun like I
mean there's been a lot of other funny
movies I'm not saying that um
um yeah but I get what you're saying it
was like The Hangover super bad it was
like the other guys is [__] hilarious
that was sort of the last gasp of
like for no reason at all like this is
just [__] funny because it's funny
you know and luckily like Netflix is one
of the places that is just willing to
roll the dice a little more than than
other places because it matters because
they're charging 20 to Adam
I know you have a movie there I get why
you're doing this but because you're
charging 20 a month they have to roll
the dice because they need content and
they don't have the office anymore
no so all the NBC shows by the way it's
coming out now that those are the
reasons that we're keeping Netflix
afloat was not new stuff they were
putting out but people wanted to watch
the office Parks and Rec like old [__]
you want a mask you want to put someone
there's a [__] thousand episodes of
right and it'll just auto play while
you're chilling that's what that is
Netflix issue leave on for your pets
when you're not there and yeah and and
they got rid of the office and neck or
whatever they move it to the peacock and
it's like nobody's gonna want nobody's
gonna go to Peacock to watch it
so much less like like like the machine
and Sebastian's movie um about my father
I think uh the fact that they put both
of those movies out on the same weekend
I'm like that [__] sucks
no no the movie's [__] Adam Adam Adam
the movies [__] suck okay Bert
Kreischer is having an existential
meltdown I saw him on a clip of him of
Brooke Chrysler on some [__] show and
he was talking about like and this is a
real thing he said like these aren't
bits he was saying something like yeah
yeah you know somebody said maybe you
drink a little bit too much he goes no I
don't think I'm an alcoholic I think I
drink a lot of alcohol but I don't think
an alcoholic and then he goes and
honestly you know what I'm doing and
this is going to sound horrible like
when I'm on private jets I don't drink
like when I'm on private jets that's
what I used to like think about stuff
and it came out so arrogant and so full
of this is a real clip where these
[__] Bert Kreischer lately it's
almost been a super cut you can find it
I forget which guy but like of Burke
Chrysler is is falling he's gonna be
dead really soon you know
I mean he's gonna be dead really soon
it's like if you look at sagora and you
look at for Chrysler they are two
different trajectories like sagoras like
losing weight getting in shape you know
[__] doing his thing and and crisis
yeah it's like not even in great shape
but he's not basic I'm gonna hang on
just keep myself under a certain way yes
maintain I'm still gonna be a schlubby
kind of chubby [__] middle-aged guy
but there's a difference between I've
totally given up and you're like okay
three days a week I can get out there
and do a [__] yeah
and that's what I mean like they cut out
the boots a couple days a week you know
yeah yeah yeah it really it really is
wild but like look at this I mean look
honestly I credit where credit is due
right like this is uh this is what this
is what's so good this is what segora is
uh let me pull it up here this is what
he's this is what he looks like now good
for him right look at that that's
awesome oh wow yeah he's in yeah he's in
pretty good shape like he's he's uh can
we get Chrysler yeah let's see Chrysler
find any photo he looks the same I got
it I got it I got it D here you go you
want to see him next to each other yeah
wait wait wait
wait oh what the [__] yeah
yeah he is he is uh he is bad uh
uh I mean he seems about as fat as he's
always been but he just looks rough and
he's got that red rosacea kinda that's
what I was saying so yeah so so when I
when I was watching uh the clip I was
noticing his face looks really bad you
know uh starting to get that like
Rudolph knows that alcoholics get yeah
yeah yeah he is you know we get it you
take your shirt off but like
he he is
we get it you take your shirt off but
that's his whole thing you know oh the
machine he's looking great
uh looking real good looking real good
Bert